violencia en las calles de beirut el
caos comenzó con la convocatoria frente
al palacio de justicia de la capital por
parte de hezbolá grupo armado y político
chiíta en contra de estar evitar el juez
encargado de la investigación de la
explosión en el puerto de beirut en 2020
que dejó al menos 200 muertos y 6.500
heridos
se han dado múltiples errores errores
cometidos por el nuevo investigador que
deben ser reconsiderados para que las
familias de las víctimas no se
conviertan en víctimas ellas mismas
yo le diría eres una persona conocida
por tu imparcialidad y moralidad protege
esa imparcialidad y esa historia era
evitar es acusado de posicionamiento
político ya que la mayoría de los
imputados son cercanos a los grupos
hezbollah llamado un proceso que de
momento está paralizado tras la denuncia
de dos de los políticos llamados a
testificar pero el descontento social de
una parte de la sociedad libanesa es tan
persistente que los tiroteos siguieron a
pesar del despliegue militar y de los
llamados a la calma del gobierno y del
propio grupo hezbollah algo que hace
peligrar el recién estrenado gabinete de
gobierno que también enfrenta una
profunda crisis económica en líbano